I uploaded the first exposing video and
it was like a pretty much like I wanted
to talk about it so bad but they really
will give you money only because on NDA
but I like Loki was like running out of
money at that point right take care of
my whole family like it was getting low
still said [__] like I'm not folding I
told my mom like bro you got she's
retired for like a decade now but I'm
like Mom like I might I'll sell my car
I'll sell everything I got but like I'm
not selling my voice bro yeah I can't I
just can't like no matter what happens
like because you can just make money
again exactly exactly dude my soul my
like brawl field like a piece of [__]
like a [__] like I want to be the man
who I say am so I can't do anything that
contradicts that foreign